hello friends and welcome to gamespot of
Thrones our weekly video show where we
talk about everything to do with s las
Westeros and everything in between I'm
Lucy James joined this week by Kate gray
hello and Dave Jewett howdy so we're
going to talk about season 6 episode 2
home and my goodness do we have a lot to
talk about so consider this your spoiler
warning because there's we pulling no
punches with this episode cuz a lot of
stuff happened it was awesome it looks
like hypes back on the menu boys and
girl let's kick things off then with a
brief recap of last night's episode
everything seemed to happen in the North
like the north is where everything went
down so Kate can you please start us off
by talking about everywhere else okay
we'll start off in King's Landing where
Sir say is trapped in her room moping
turns out the King has forced her to
stay there and she does have the
mountain with her and he's crushing
skills in service of his lady so that's
pretty cool jamie is threatening the
high Sparrow but the high Sparrow
threatens him right back brings all his
men in it's a very intense and Tommen
finally reunites with his mother which
is sweet
over in marine Tyrion and Varys our
bantering like the best of bros but
tyrion decides it's time to wake the
Dragons he goes over to them he goes I'm
friends with your mother please don't
eat me and they seem to accept that you
know maybe that he can be hurt their
friend too and then he takes their
chains off so the fleet might have been
burned but they still have the most
important ship friendship next time I
have an idea like that punch me in the
face over in Braavos we have arya
training with the wife again basically
we only cut to aria when she's been hit
with the stick so that's that's nice
she's not very good at fighting but then
Jack and her girl shows up finally and
maybe he's in there the whole time maybe
he's the wife maybe he's waiting for him
and he says if a girl says her name a
man will feed her if a girl says her
name a man will give her her eyes back
and we see arya pause she's meant to say
a girl is no one or I'm no one but at
that bit she's like imagine if I had
eyes again but she does pass the test
she says I'm no one and he takes her
away saying a girl is not a beggar
anymore that's pretty exciting what did
we think that I'm excited also a girl
must become daredevil yes basically
what's happening yeah pretty much all
right Dave the North please so the
episode actually started in the north
where you said most the interesting
things is happening so bran is is
hanging out with his tree friend the
three-eyed Raven / crow depending on
better than I your book reader seemed to
change it and we get to see him have his
first major it's not like flashback I
guess you'd call it all those not his
flashback green sea yeah great green sea
into the into the site where he sees
young Ned training with benjin and were
introduced to Lyanna stark putting a
face to Ned sister finally I've been
hearing about her since the episode 1
although she's been dead but we can see
her storyline develop now hopefully um
then another favorite character turns up
although he's certainly got the ability
to speak Hodor this leaves the hood or
is it it's a Willis do you can say it
you can do the line what you talked
about will is
I guess we watched it together that's
all we said yeah and he's not currently
the simple-minded half giant that he
becomes later on in the series so maybe
we'll get to see what happens there some
tense moments the wall hmm where Sir
Davos is holed up guarding John's body
with a loyal men of the Nights Watch and
just when the thing we can call the
traitors just about to knock their way
in old 11 the giant comes a knocking
knocks down the cake the the gate of
Castle black that's kicking some ass all
the cowards nice was just immediately
dropped with the drop their weapons
apart from Alistair thorne and bloody
Ollie thousands of years the Nights
Watch has held Castle black against the
wildlings until you some big change to
Windsor Winterfell mm-hmm Ramsay wants
to storm Castle black from the south
having obviously no idea that it's now
full of wildlings I wants to kill John
before Santa can get there as this is
going on as this train of thought has
been discussed ruse Bruce's son is born
from a fat Walder and you can kind of
see Ramsay being a bit like oh dear Ben
want to think of this and I have a sweet
embrace Andrew says you're still my for
a son hey it's dad yep shank Ramsay just
straight up stabs the fool and then we
get to see what was probably the darkest
moment one of the darkest moments of
Game of Thrones ranks like yeah top
three yeah spoilers but Ramsay feeds fat
Walder and her newborn been alive for
about 20 minutes to his dogs she's
walking like remarkably well for a woman
who just gave birth yeah considering
yeah baby is off a blue in the cold but
that melted the popular Ramsay
he's your brother
I prefer being an only child
but then this is basically the north
part two because so much happened we saw
myself reunion scene of Brienne and
Santa and sons are kind of admitting I
should have gone with you and then they
a tearful goodbye to wreak because I
thought I thought we'd work on the
hallway but he decides to go home back
to the island of pike which helpfully
was the next scene where we get some
Greyjoy actions so the Greyjoy's been
missing for a little bit bow on Greyjoy
and Yara kind of their butting heads a
bit because she wants peace and he's
like no we've lost our foothold on the
on the mainland we need to get that back
and Yara so quite gorgeous live in Pisa
you know we're not we're not good on
land and he says well you know you'll
never rule at this rate turns out he
won't be ruling for much longer either
because his brother you're on comes back
the Cherokee does a really good job of
kind of explaining his character in a
very short amount of time basically he
he's got a little bit of the ocean
madness and he just straight up kills
his brother and says you know like
you've--you been king for too long
you've lost it I am the drowned God I
mean you know he is the storm he's storm
pushes brother off a bridge and that
kind of instigates a Kingsmoot they have
to decide who their new king will be so
that'll be like the Greyjoy hotline for
a little bit and then we go back to the
wall and I mean this was pretty much the
least surprising turn of events ever I
mean everyone knew we are new Davos
reminds Melisandre that she has magical
powers because she's like no probably
cannot do it he's like mob scene you
give birth to a shadow baby uh and she
goes ok gives him a bit of a rub down
like an excessively long rubdown rubdown
and a haircut well you don't we don't do
in that situation oh yeah ladies I'd
like yeah this is definitely part of the
ritual and he's back so our lovely
wildling lover is still alive yay Kate
what did you make of admittedly the
least surprising reveal of all time well
I think it's it's good that it finally
happened
I'm glad that it happened because you
know there was so much tension
especially in that last episode with the
wiping and the hair cutting and you know
that scene is only there just to make
you go is this going to work is it not
going to work you know after all that
we're thinking it's definitely gonna
happen but then it didn't happen and we
were like oh god is I think the cruelest
trick also when ghosts opened his eyes
for her Oh No so yeah he's not we don't
think he's walked into ghosts and if he
has then like so what nothing happened
of it so ghost is happy John is
presumably a little happier having been
made alive again I love holes though mm
that's true I mean for all the people
who are dead and have been resurrected
he's not the worst looking no he's a
little bit blue he's got some holes here
and there but we actually see in the
preview next week his back still looks
really nice and he's got a nice heck yes
had a nice haircut so what do we think
it's gonna happen to Melisandre now that
you know she's lost her faith but maybe
it'll come back she's brought joked on
snow back to life they called up Joe so
Joe snow I don't think it's the end
we've seen of her I know kind of seems
like hope storylines petered out a
little bit yeah but I think that if I
mean like we saw in the preview for the
next week's episode that they think he's
a God reborn and ozora hi I'd like to
think that she kind of latches onto to
that and sort of like her her misplaced
faith in the Lord of Light kind of you
know she she rallies around John cuz I
like her as a character you know she's
always been just this great staple I
think of just like mystery in Game of
Thrones so I don't want to see no I mean
I do think they left the room a little
bit quickly given that she was you know
doing all this stuff maybe it takes more
than like 30 seconds for the ritual to
work just stick around and they hadn't
left the room for ages up until that
point so I didn't why didn't they just
stay there for a bit longer I don't know
but what do we thinks gonna happen next
for off favorite bastard well now he's
you know woken up the world llings gonna
be like hey man you're that cool guy and
now that we've we've seen what's
happened to Ramsey and we know what he
wants his objective is to match the wall
gonna see some of these characters butt
heads finally yeah it's nice to see
different character in Game of Thrones
you haven't like we're in season six and
they haven't interacted really at all
it's kind of nice to see sort of just
all these threads and paths crossing and
if anyone's gonna put her on Ramsey yeah
John I can't wait till he gets over the
Narrow Sea mr. narrow so they can marry
and have beautiful Targaryen babies
Ramsey's just like I don't want to say
that he went from nought to 100 cuz he's
always been in like 70 but he went from
like 72 like a thousand in this week's
episode he just like this is the
craziest I think I've ever seen him I
love it I love Ramsay's character no
Dave you've got some opinions about Mad
Dog Ramsay yeah so last week we did
predict quite accurately in fact that he
would kill his father based on how much
we see of him in the trailer and you
know Ramsey being mental yeah and then
we didn't quite we didn't quite realize
how he would dispatch his extended
family so we did think that maybe if
lady Walda did give birth to a son and
you would see that as a threat could
drive him to to murder but he kills his
father stabs him you know that's get us
Game of Thrones when I won't ever get
stabbed yeah and then he leads lady
Walda into the kennels and the guise of
taking her to rooster show him his her
new his new little baby boy but like she
must know the layout of Winterfell why
would she go there it's not it's not
other realms possibility that she thinks
ruses in the kennels maybe until you
know he starts opening all the cages
yeah this is it's a bit dark but a bit a
bit dark a baby cosmina a newborn baby
give me and a life by dogs not a
hospital I don't know if that was a
newborn baby I think that's a bit of a
plot hole that you know they go you've
got a son and then she's just walking
around like normal not gonna happen
whatever as Ramsay said he prefers to be
an only child mm-hmm and then whistles
sets the sets the hounds and release
down Walder lady Walda and a named small
newborn what is Rameses obsession with
dogs he isn't that dog hmm he's my dog
dog no dog mm-hmm doggy dog world
exactly doesn't talk dirty puppy baby
and Doug eat fat woman human why are we
really surprised about Randy's actions
is this the worst he's been to be
expected to do any worse it's not the
worst he's been but newborn baby
literally 20 minutes old well maybe it
is I be cut off someone's weiner doing a
baby I guess technically that's worse
but he's always been quite cold and
calculated in a mad kind of way and the
tension in that moment was just awful
like he knew what he was going to do
from the minute he saw lady Walder in
the courtyard he was like come with me
into the kennels whoops wrong place oh
no the dogs escaped oh look you're dead
now haha what's really unsettling as I
think like he did all of this in front
of people yeah the fact that the
entirety of all of his men all of his
subjects all of Winterfell are so scared
of him he can do that blatantly in the
open hearing all the scream seeing his
father get stabbed and nobody even looks
twice yeah he's like that much fear
behind him what was so interesting to me
is that ruse I guess always had this
control over him and it was sort of like
ultimately him legitimizing Ramsay which
started his downfall yeah like I didn't
need him anymore yeah he kept pushing
him and he kept saying things like if
you want to be the Mad Dog if you want
to be a psychopath your ideas to storm
Castle black it's stupid blah blah he
played these games with her you and your
games yeah and like he knows what his
son is like but I guess something must
have blinded him to think the Ramsey
would never turn on him and so when he
did uh it was kind of delicious although
it was dark skip pay back a little bit a
little bit that mad dog line is
definitely foreshadowing if you're gonna
act like a mad dog they'll treat you
like a mad dog and I forget the bit
after the exit in write it down but
something about getting killed so
basically unless unless like it's for
shouting Ramsay's ultimate end and that
the dogs turn on him I don't know if
it's gonna be dogs I think that would be
nice but they're too well-trained life
ghost kills him Oh that'd be nice one on
one with Jon Snow and then goes just go
to the jugular I actually yeah I'm up to
that
I want to take a brief moment to say
welcome back to the Greyjoy's they have
been absent for quite some time and they
kind of do they do play a big role in
the books they have a couple of POV
characters and I thought it was great to
sort of introduce your on and he was
introduced like in the book he's sort of
even more crazy but they gave a really
good introduction and just how warped he
is um k and i have read read the books
but Dave what did you think of the
introduction to your own because you've
this is the first time you've really met
his character yeah so he appears on the
bridge and you can tell after like a
brief conversation he's a little bit you
know not all there let's say and he
keeps referring to himself as i am the
drowned God I am the storm and the whole
part where he was he says he goes mad in
a storm and his crew tie him to the mast
keep him from my hurt himself everyone
else when he's free cuts everyone's
tongues out yeah the ship's called
silence which is you know how makes
sense yeah and just just the way he
carries himself he seems very cold I
mean the Greyjoy's are cold anyway he
seems just completely just not there
when it comes to violence and killing
his brother yeah when we think about the
implications for yarra so we know that
Yara is kind of more you know peaceful
now I guess she sort of realized that
the Greyjoy's don't have a good standing
to get a foothold on the mainland Kate I
think Yara's gonna have a bit of a maybe
a bit of a sansa moment in that she's
saying things and no one's listening to
her she gets pushed to the back they
underestimate her because she's a woman
that happens a lot in Game of Thrones so
I don't think it's out of the realms of
possibility but you know I'd like to see
her get some power cuz she's badass and
she's great in the books she's almost as
great in the TV series but I I think
ultimately she's she's not going to get
listen to mmm what I why thought was
quite interesting so in the books you're
on actually ends up going across to
Essos but it looks like from the
trailers it'll actually be Yara because
there's one point where she's you can
see her with a [ __ ] in volantis because
she's got like this tattoo so we quite
interesting to see that if they kind of
split those stories a little bit and
just sort of swap the characters around
a bit which I think
cool that would be nice although based
on the books I really hope it's more
interesting I hated the Greyjoy chapter
so much I don't know like I just think
it's there an interesting sort of family
they have a very bizarre dynamic and
everyone's just vying for power all the
time and it's just there's just a little
bit different I mean the moot happening
and apparently Theon is heading back
there yeah moot could be between Yara
mm-hmm Theon and and you're on and
anyone else he wants to turn up yeah I
mean what's a great joys out there
that's the thing i mean like we think we
know the way that it's gonna pan out but
as the show was proven so many times
that we know nothing we know absolutely
nothing not to blow our own trumpets
here but we did pretty well with the
predictions that we made last week so we
totally called that Ramsey was gonna
kill ruse you totally called The
Princess Bride resurrection yeah and hey
mutton was key uh and we totally called
that um you know Terry and dragons of a
part yes so we're doing pretty well this
week I'm gonna start off with bastard
Bowl which i think is really exciting so
we know that Ramsey I mean I actually
first let's have a moment of silence for
Roose Bolton um you know rip it's his
own fault really he should have seen
what Ramsay a capable of the triad I
have no sympathy for the man so we know
where Ramsey definitely wants to take on
Castle black he wants to kill Jon Snow
and he thinks that he has all the
Northern armies in which to do so so
he's got the umbers the Karstarks and
the man delays we don't need every house
in the north the umbers the mandala sand
the cast dogs command more soldiers than
all the other houses combined with air
support none co challenges so he's got
like a pretty sizable force and as he
says like the Castle black it's just
like rapists and murderers and petty
thieves they're not really trained
there's not very many of them and it's
not defended from the south either yeah
so he sees this as a pretty easy win but
he also doesn't know that John died and
has been resurrected and is now kind of
scene is like this godlike figure from
the wildlings and also that he's managed
to get the wildlings on side and the
wildlings I mean there's a lot of them
yep oh yeah and a giant I'm guessing he
definitely doesn't know about when when
the giant so we also know that Santa's
on her way up there to reunite with John
so John like before he's always been a
man of honor doesn't want to get
involved but now he has like this
personal connection mm-hmm so he's gonna
want revenge on behalf of Sansa so if we
take like if you look at like a book
theory here so when Lady Stoneheart was
resurrected it was Catelyn Stark and she
was kind of overcome with vengeance so
I'm interested to see if John will be
different if he won't be like as honor
bound and peaceful as before if he will
be like more Lord stone ha let's just
say time to kick some ass John yeah nice
kick in John um but also to do with
bastard bowl I hang this line from the
current Lord Karstark is quite
interesting and I think it leads into
what's gonna happen next week your hold
on the north will never be secured as
long as a star can walk through that
door and in the trailer for episode 3 we
hear someone say I brought you a gift
and right before that happens that flag
looks a lot like the ombre flag and we
know that Rick on was taken there so
basically if Ramsey's gift cuz we when
we were watching we wish we thought he'd
be reek I am the kids been captured and
returned him yeah but really all Ramsay
needs is a stark in the north and if
he's got recon whatever forgot about the
worst of the Starks well bran um no I
mean so like he basically has everything
so here's everything he needs john wants
like revenge bastard ball guys snowball
snowball none of the bastards but all of
the bastards there's so many I mean the
show has so many balls I do think as
well next episode is called Oathbreaker
and we are thinking that maybe the
person breaking their oath is jon snow
because you only have to keep the Nights
Watch oath until you die and he died
that's brilliant think about that oh no
cuz we hey when we already went and we
thought he'd be like Brienne because her
sword is obvious called oathkeeper but
she's fulfilled her oath now yeah she's
found Santa so
kate gray actually work it might finally
be time for one of the biggest game of
Thrones fan theories to be confirmed
cage one take this one yes lightly as he
says it's the most exciting it's r + l
equals J the theory that Rhaegar and
Lyanna had a baby it was Jon Snow and
Ned adopted him and pretended he was
just some bastard that he done did we
see Brown looking into Ned Stark's past
in this episode and we also see that
it's going to happen in next episode so
in this episode you see Ned at
Winterfell training with his brother
Benjen and you see Leo for the first
time which is very exciting because we
know that means she's gonna be a part of
these little green seeing trips that
he's having so next week we see that Ned
is standing outside some kind of tower
fighting some guards could it be the
Tower of joy well they are Targaryen
guards and that guy yep can I gonna
shout out to that guy for his Ned Stark
accent and impression because it is a
lot on and now begins now attends so for
non book readers like myself what is the
Tower of joy so the Tower of joy is a
tower built specifically by raiga for
Liana he keeps her in there because he
doesn't want anyone to touch her so
during Robert's rebellion she is up in
that Tower doing god knows what and when
Ned actually enters her room she's there
in a bed of blood as its described in
the books and she dies in his arms with
the words promise me Ned on her lips and
we know that he sees winter roses blue
roses those are kind of Leon a symbol
those are what Rhaegar gives her when he
crowned so the queen of love and beauty
so it's all very symbolic but the r plus
l equals J theory states that Liana's
bed of blood is actually a child bed
having just given birth to Reagan's baby
ie Jon Snow mm-hmm so this might finally
be the moment when we find out what went
on in that tower whether Liana actually
had a baby at what she died of exactly
and whether John is actually the blood
of the dragon and there's a little
interesting side theory might not be
entirely
and I'm not anywhere near as invested in
this one but me reread is currently a
company brand in the north she's very
bored as we see in this episode now
Mira's father is Howland Reed who is
currently m.i.a but he is the only
surviving person that was at the Tower
of joy that day so there are theories as
to whether Mara knows the tale her dad
told her the tail and she will somehow
be key in helping friend understand what
went on or even more interestingly
mirror is another R + L baby the twin
sister of john and they split the twin
babies up gave one to Ned want to
Howland they went off grew up look kind
of similar in that they both have dark
curly hair and you know I don't think
that's that's probably not true because
yeah so what but mmm there's another
theory for you Kenny seems to me that
people have been like sort of half
ignoring mirror this whole time yeah so
I'm less convinced about that pub I
think that the heard dad being there
were definitely yes how repercussion cuz
i think this episode they definitely
seeding the fact that she's like oh well
i'm here but there's no point in me
being here and the girls like no you
know you must be there for bran I think
that's good time for death of the week
and boy do we have some contenders this
week last week is pretty cut and dry it
was it was trystane it was he was the
best death this week though we each have
our own nomination so I'm going to start
just the drunk flash a guy who the
mountain just just crashes his head like
yeah coconut like a well that's pretty
difficult to crush with just your face
but I think the man at the Marion where
the mountain could do it I i think when
we were watching it we all just saw when
wave avid i like to think that the
mountain did that not for Cersei but for
Jamie because that guy said Jamie was
half an inch short of an inch imagines
like no he's not I've seen it mate I
think you might just done I boredom he's
just he just then use that I'm not
killed anyone to take care yeah I bet I
would if I was that strong my death of
the week is one that wasn't actually on
screen it would you say they actually
died though I know these guys don't they
died they died it's lady Walda and her
named newborn it was a bit of a similar
situation to Shireen in that you can
hear them screaming for ages I do hope
that Ramsey gets what's coming to him
though because he is a bastard in every
sense of the word legitimize now though
he is it a gia bastard
my death of the week we don't get to see
too much the awesome Giants fighting
especially since 11 is the last one but
my death the week goes to mr.
trigger-happy crossbowman on the
ramparts of Castle black I don't quite
know what he was thinking this one
crossbow bolt it's just gonna is like a
roses thorn to this giant and in return
he gets made into a human paintbrush
grabbed with a limb spot against the
wall and just discarded it's pretty
badass good grief so there was a ton of
food for thought in the episode
personally a really strong one for me I
really loved it lots of plots going on
what's a good deaths as well lots of
intrigue super excited for episode 3
Oathbreaker Kate what you think I think
this this series so far is interesting
it's going a lot heavier on the big
deaths than previous seasons did they
tended to save them up to them all at
once like the road wedding um so I'm
liking it so far I hope they don't run
out of people to kill that's the great
thing my camera thrones' that were
exactly when people die because we're
awful like that Dave I'm really excited
like you said the they're setting up
more stuff if I like episode 1 was where
they got a lot the set up out of the way
and then episode 2 they kind of
capitalized it mmm I'll also have a few
more things or just developed on current
plot lines but as we're seeing these
plot lines like go on and on and seeing
all these new characters get introduced
and old characters get pretty murdered
it's all good stuff all great game of
thrones content strong a couple of
episodes at the start of season 6 that's
all good time for this week make sure to
join us every monday youtube.com slash
gamespot or cross games or calm or on
itunes if you'd prefer an audio version
to listen on your commute into work or
in your lunch break check it out at
iTunes you can find me on Twitter at
Lucy James games ok I'm at how not to
draw and Dave and I am at a regular Dave
and we'll see you next week
you